how many times have you heard a kid say
I hate maths or I don't do maths em have
even said it yourself in high school but
one exceptional enthusiastic teacher is
reinvigorating high school maths helping
thousands of students to not only
understand maths but to actually enjoy
it Eddie Wu is the head of massive
cherry book technology high school but
also the creator of an online classroom
called word tube which is have nearly 4
million views you may have seen him
featured on Australian story recently
Eddie Wu joins me in the studio hi I
could really go to be here how much for
coming in I bet you've never thought
that math teaching would be the path to
celebrity when you think about you know
a list be a list of every site how many
letters on it how far you want to go
down
it certainly wasn't something that I
expected or anticipated it was funny how
things going to bit crazy since your
Australian story episode went to air oh
look it's just been amazing the
responsible people have been given and
people have been so positive towards it
and I think that what sort of struck
people is how human this story has been
and how everyone I suppose has a story
oh yeah web hearing and listening to and
is inspiring once you learn the details
of it so I've just been yea really
flattered by everyone and honored to be
a part of it oh that's great so what
attracted you to a career in teaching
Eddy when I was at school I had the
wonderful privilege of number one being
able to see great teachers who really
made a difference to the students they
taught and also I had the opportunity to
take part in lots of little
opportunities where I got to experience
what it's like to help someone else
learn and to see someone who is younger
than me and have the opportunity to help
them grow like you you were given
leadership opportunities from an early
age yes and I can I can think of you
know I did peer support leading which is
a great fun at a year 11 student you
need little you sevens who've just come
into the school and helping them you
know realize this is not something to be
scared of it's a wonderful opportunity
to move into the high school things like
Cadets things like prefect and also I
was a leader in my high school Christian
group and that gave me a great
opportunity not just to be in the you
know running events and organising
things but actually taking care of
people and seeing them
or and from the little people who you
know they're just wondering what am I
supposed to do with my life and how do I
tie my shoelaces in all that to making
decisions and charting a path for their
own life it's pretty amazing
so is that nurturing role that you
really relish for me I love my subject
without a doubt you know I would get to
talk about interesting things all day
but I think the thing that switches me
on the most and year to year makes me
most excited is seeing children move
forward and become something different
from what they were before and grow up
and realize their place in the world
that's very inspiring um I know that you
shared in your story how your parents
migrated to Australia so that you would
have better opportunities here than they
could give you in Malaysia so how did
your family react when you told them
that you're going into a teaching career
I think they maybe thought it was just
going to be a phase you know our dishes
well what is the sixteen-year-old know
about what they're going to do in life
and to be fair I really wasn't sure it
was kind of like a theme this seems like
a good fear you know I thought about the
things that I enjoyed doing but I also
thought about the contribution I wanted
to make to society and a community and
the skills that I had and how they'd be
able to serve people and so I think you
know eventually they came to realize oh
this is something he's serious about and
something he actually has a passion for
and so I eventually they came around so
it wasn't really what they expect of
their high achieving son I have a very
wise daddy that your own school
experience has affected the way that you
teach I think that when I look back at
my own school experience they were parts
that were really difficult there were
challenges that I faced you know being
quite an isolated child and not knowing
that my older brother and sister got
along really well together were quite
close in age and here I was off at the
end a bit of a bookish sort of child and
I just I never had heaps of friends
especially when I was very young so now
that I'm a teacher I realized that the
importance of actually looking out for
people who don't always draw attention
every child is unique and special and
important and so it's definitely a big
part of my job every day yeah right so
reaching out to those who may be a
little bit on the sidelines I'm speaking
to Eddie whoo he's had a massive
cherrybrook technology high school but
also the career
of this online classroom called woo -
which has had 4 million hits you've said
before that math didn't come naturally
to you so what changed with that I think
when I was at school math is something
which I sort of could do but can really
understand and I felt like I didn't need
to understand it I could just go through
steps get an answer at the end and that
was enough but then when I got to
university I realized that okay I want
to be a teacher because I wanna make a
difference to kids I don't really mind
what subject I'm going to teach so long
as I can interact with young people and
help them that was how I actually moved
from wanting to teach English history to
say okay I'm going to take a bit of a
leap of faith here literally and go down
this Avenue and I realized okay if I'm
gonna have to teach this it's not enough
to just be able to do it I've got to
know why I've got to go back to being a
little kid who just questions everything
and what's the reason behind everything
and when I engage in that that level and
kept on asking well okay but why do we
do this or why does this make sense or
why is this pattern the way it is then I
realized oh there's something of great
beauty here to appreciate and that's
when things change for me okay so what
so what is it that you would say you
really love about maths now I guess the
thing that I love right now that I mean
there's so many different aspects of it
it's a practical thing it's all around
us the thing that I think is most deeply
hitting me and resonating with me at the
moment is that just like say something
like music is something which you can
just sort of let breeze pass to you and
it's as part of your world but if you
stop and you listen there's something
deep and beautiful to appreciate there
there's almost an aesthetic experience
and for me mathematics
I mean I think love something like say a
bolt of lightning through the sky in the
middle of a storm and you hardly get to
see one because it flashes by literally
so quickly but lightning bolts are
always characteristic shape why are they
why is a lightning bolt shape what it is
and there's a beautiful little piece of
method notes underneath it called a
fractal and that kind of shape is
everywhere in nature once you start
looking for it and realizing oh there's
a reason for this things just on a
coincidence our world has been designed
and there are beautiful patterns just
waiting to be discovered
I think I really like that I love that
almost getting me interested in maths
Eddy this is the main
thing let's talk about your Roux Tube
channel that's attracted a lot of
attention what was the inspiration
behind starting that up about five years
ago now I had a student he was very very
ill he was diagnosed with pancreatic
cancer which is pretty violent as a
disease for anyone let alone a 16 year
old boy and so he would spend weeks and
weeks away from school and I think it's
pretty challenging to learn any subject
when you have to spend weeks and weeks
away from school but mathematics in
particular every topic every concept
every skill is built up on top of the
others so you take out one little brick
and the whole thing just collapses like
a house of cards
so I thought all right we need to be
able to do something better for this
child he deserves better than this why
don't I just start recording the lessons
that I do just what the rest of the
class is experiencing without him and
make them available so that at anytime
he can just sort of keep up along with
us won't be the same but if we better
than just saying he's the textbook
that's very committed thing to do for a
teacher Eddy do you think that the fact
that you had your own family experience
of cancer made you just more empathetic
to what he was going through I
definitely remember as a high school
student my mother was diagnosed with
cancer when I was in year 10 and all the
way through my senior years that had a
huge impact on my entire family so I
think that was obviously a part of it
but I do want to point of the fact that
all teachers you know resourcefulness
particularly when you when you think
about the limited number amount of time
and and resources that you have that's
just something we all do we improvise
solutions and we try and come up with
just what's best for the kids
yeah that's that's a lot of full skill
for kids to learn as well how do you
feel about the fact that now you know
students all around the world and in
remote areas are also learning from your
maths lessons for me it's just
astonishing I mean I get emails and
sometimes even letters and cards from
kids are not even kids even people
who've left school and they've had
positive or negative experiences of
learning mathematics and will write in I
got this lovely Christmas card actually
from a 50 year old dentist who sent me a
little message say I watched this video
about Euler's identity which even among
us mathematics
that's a pretty nerdy thing to get
excited about and he was just delighted
to be able to experience that in a way
that made sense to him so for me it's
just incredible and speaks to the value
of making our learning available
publicly and freely I love that because
you know I mean not everyone can have
access to cherrybrook technology hi I
mean people I know try and buy houses in
that area just to get their kids into
that school because it has such a strong
reputation and not everyone can afford
to live in an area like that so the fact
that you're making this available and
kids anywhere can access this fantastic
teaching that's it that's a beautiful
thing yeah for me it's sort of
emblematic of the fact that you know all
of us and I personally know this myself
because my own lived experience have
received so much grace in our lives and
often we're never in a position to pay
it back to the people who gave it to us
so what an opportunity we have therefore
to pay it forward and take the resources
and gifts that we've been given and
freely give that to others I think it's
a wonderful opportunity to have yeah and
you mentioned grace you've mentioned a
bit about your faith how would you say
your Christian faith influences your
work for me being a Christian means that
the reason I exist in this world is to
serve to contribute something to my
community to love people and be kind to
them and therefore as a teacher number
one just it's my job to look after
children and to help them grow and to
provide them with opportunities and help
them realize the things that they're
capable of which many children aren't
but secondly it just for me informs the
sense of care that I have to staff
students parents all the people who are
interact with being a Christian means
that I want to do that in a way that's
caring and shows love and grace to the
people around me mmm
careful I'm sure a lot of teachers are
going to be inspired by what you've
achieved I know there's a lot of awards
and things out there with your name on
it what do you want other teachers to
learn from your story for me I hope it
helps encourage other teachers because
the first thing on the forefront of mind
is that teaching is hard and teaching is
usually a thankless job it's really sad
how many people who are dedicated to
their students as educators go through
their entire lives and maybe don't hear
about the kind of impact that they've
had
add on there the people who have walked
through their classrooms for many many
years
I hope teachers realize that the impact
they can have on an individual the
impact that my teachers have had on me
is just so important so massive just
immeasurable really
I hope they realize that it's an
encouragement for them to keep on going
in day after day and doing a good work
over a long time that's true because I
think when people hold up a teacher like
yourself they're also I guess honoring
all the other teachers as well who do
their job day-in day-out so yeah Thank
You Eddie
it's a pleasure Katrina thank you yes
anywhere he's a head of mass at travel
technology high school and the creator
of the whoo - online classroom